as israel steps up its military
activity in gaza hospitals there say
crucial treatments like dialysis are
having to be scaled back because of
electricity and fuel shortages a warning
that the images we about to show you of
people being taken into one hospital
this is the hospital in central gaza
which has been overwhelmed
as intelligence and in death of aing h
fig
ofs هذا اليوم يوم الاحد يوم دامي
للمحافظه الوسطى قصف عشوائ بلا هوا على
جميع مخيمات المحافظه الوسطى من الساعه
الثامنه بالامس ليلا حتى حتى اللحظه القصف
لم يتوقف على المحافظه الوسطى احصائيه
شهداء اليوم 166 شهيد حتى اللحظه واكثر من
300 جريح ليصبح الاجمالي للمحافظه الوسطى
12200 1
1247 شهيد 1247 شهيد واكثر من 2900 جريح
اي احصا يه شهداء وجرحى المحافظه الوسطى
يوم دامي بالفعل لا يمكن لا يمكن بالطبع
لاي مستشفى في العالم ان يتقبل كل هذا
العدد من الاصابات ولا يمكن لاي طاقم
التعامل مع هذا الكم سيما ان الجرحى يحتاج
الى عده تخصصات كل جريح يحتاج الى اربع
خمس تخصصات جراحيه هذا يلقي بظلاله على
الطاقم الطبي من عناء وا طبعا لا يمكن
تقديم الخدمه للمرضى كما هو في الوضع
الطبيعي بدون حروب اصابات بالجمله لا يوجد
سعه سريريه في المستشفى لهؤلاء
الجرحى الجرحى على ابواب العمليات مقدسين
كل ينتظر دوره والوضع كارثي للغايه في
مستشفى شهد
الاقصى ضربه جديده بالقرب من مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى استهداف اخر حاله من الزعر داخل
هذه
المستشفى حاله من الزعر استهداف اخر بقرب
من مستشفى ال الاقصى اليوم دير
البلح اليوم دير
[موسيقى]
البلح عشرات من
الشهداء غاره اسرائيليه اخرى اكثر من خمس
غارات بجوار المستشفى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يلا